estávamos no verão de 1999
alguns de vocês ainda não eram neste
outro estavam na barriga e nossa mãe
outros já cá estavam fora expressar
emoções ou por outras palavras recebidas
eu tinha acabado de receber uma notícia
que transformar a minha vida tinha
acabado de saber que ia conseguir entrar
no instituto superior técnico
meu pai estava orgulhoso toda a minha
família de deus pra baixo e um treino
técnico no curso de engenharia
electrotécnica e de computadores e vamos
dizer foi um dos anos mais chão em vez
da minha vida
a decisão de estudar engenharia foi
baseada basicamente naquela frase
popular é um curso com saída na verdade
é que eu consegui sair do técnico a
terminar o curso e que não é verdade
a verdade é que eu não sabia não fazia
ideia que eu queria qualquer área que eu
estava eu não fazia a mínima ideia
então uma das coisas que eu mais gostava
o técnico é quando acabava a última aula
do dia porque não estava do curso eu não
estava da maioria das cadeiras no final
do primeiro ano meu pai vai ter comigo e
perguntou então nos ajudar
naquele momento imagina a cara desilusão
do meu pai quando eu soubesse a verdade
eu não tinha sequer uma cadeira
o manual de instruções do manual de
instruções que nossa sociedade nos
ensina diz nos que é caro é fraqueza
desde os que devemos vencer
e não queria ser fraco
então o que eu fiz foi me manter sempre
eu passei viana
eu coloquei um peso em cima de mim
uma mentira que durou praticamente
quatro anos 43 anos o meu pai toda a
minha família saibam que eu estava no
terceiro ano
quando acordava eu nem sequer o primeiro
ano tinha terminado
às vezes meu pai ligavam e eu achava que
eu já tinha descoberto a verdade eu
vivia em angústia ansiedade e tristeza
certo dia vai ter comigo e disse me a
mim é mais um documento que comprova as
notas que tivessem todas as câmeras que
já fizeste eu comecei a chorar enquanto
é verdade ou não todo ser humano tem
seis cadeiras feitas
eu dizia o meu pai dos meus avós vieram
de toda a minha família são de muito
mais do que se tivesse contado logo no
primeiro ano na verdade mas mesmo assim
mesmo assim meu pai toda a minha família
me apoiaram sempre incondicionalmente
até o dia de hoje
durante o tempo que esteve como técnico
sempre que eu sentia aquela seus sonhos
desagradáveis como angústia ansiedade
tristeza eu tentava evitar essas funções
e nem sequer queria pensar nisso então
tentava distrair com a menina morava e
ouvir música tentava sempre colocaram
estado em sinal de alegria e de
confiança e foi por isso que eu
agüentaria tanto tempo
foi por isso que eu entrei tanto tempo
numa situação que odiava
num curso que não estava
foi por isso que no mundo aí eu sofri
porque não sabia lidar com as minhas
emoções nem percebi a mensagem que cada
um nos enviava me enviava conhecer sua
vez queria ser bem sucedido
então tenho que estar 100 para web
sempre confiante
não é isso que nos diz o manual de
instruções das emissões de nossa
sociedade
não chores vez que ser forte tem que
vencer tem que ser o melhor
é verdade é que não conseguimos estar
sempre alegre e confiante e como não
conseguimos e colocamos as máscaras para
esconder o nosso lado menos bom o nosso
lado mais negro
a marca do sucesso sem falhas a máscara
da confiança sem seguranças
a máscara da alegria em tristeza a
máscara da sabedoria sem dúvidas a marca
da sua prioridade máxima das redes
sociais
e aquela que eu usei durante tanto tempo
a máscara da mentira eu não sou
invencível
não sou imparável eu sou um ser humano
igual a vocês
já falei já e ray já fez muitas coisas
das quais não me orgulho
orgulho me do que aprender com as coisas
que fiz das quais não me orgulho eu não
concordo com este manual de instruções
que nossa sociedade nos vencer
este manual de instruções que diz que
devemos evitar as emoções negativas e
viver as emoções positivas e que esse é
o caminho para a felicidade porque por
todas as emoções têm uma intenção
positiva todas as funções têm intenção
positiva as funções têm um propósito de
garantir nossa sobrevivência
a nossa proteção e ajuda nos a
alcançarmos os nossos objetivos
pode haver um sonhos desagradáveis e
emoções agradáveis em funções adequadas
ao contexto e em funções adequadas ao
contexto mas todas as funções são
positivas o que pode ser negativo é
forma como lidamos com as nossas
atenções durante ford e irismar aos
investigadores da universidade de
toronto no canadá e da universidade
berkeley na califórnia estados unidos da
américa a realizar um estudo em 2018 e
publicaram um artigo em que conclusão
que chegaram é que as pessoas que
habitualmente aceitam as suas intenções
negativas sem criticar conseguem lidar
melhor com as mesmas têm melhor saúde
psicológica e maior resiliência em um
sinal a palavra-chave na conclusão deste
estudo é aceitar
nós precisamos aceitar as nossas
invenções e aceitar é de frente
resignaram aceitará soluções porque
conseguimos compreender a mensagem que
cada uma nos envia porque todas as
atenções têm uma função e uma mensagem
no estudo científico mais amigo da
universidade de jerusalém em 2017 chegou
a outra conclusão do estudo dela fui
cidade envolve presenciar em missões que
consideramos que são adequadas numa
determinada situação
ou seja se uma manhã em que fazer uma
apresentação eu vou fazer um teste por
exemplo estou estressado seu pensar eu
não quero estar estressado porque eu
estou estressado
o que eu tenho está assim sujeitar essa
função e não perceber o que é que
significa estar sala eu vou ficar mais
estressado e vamos sentir mais
influentes
então mais uma vez de aceitar e
compreender as intenções
estou estressado é porque algo
importante e os três estavam a dizer
preparado da melhor forma
nós com seres humanos temos a tendência
evitar o tudo o que é negativo
então se nós chamamos algumas invenções
um sonho negativas não ter uma maior
tendência para evitar essas emissões
a tristeza por exemplo nós tentemos
tristeza durante alguns meses alguns
anos uma forma profunda essa tristeza
não se vai embora se nós não soubermos
lidar com a tristeza ela vai crescendo
vai vai ficando um peso enorme em cima
de nós e pode mesmo transformar se em
uma doença grave com uma opção
nós precisamos de perceber e de
expressar as emoções por exemplo a nossa
sociedade condena o facto de chorarmos
no meio na maior parte das situações
uma rinha um trabalho em que alguém
começa a chorar normalmente não é bem
aceite no entanto tivemos mesma opinião
e audiências o ar não há problema nenhum
porque porque a sua área onde um ato
limpeza
chorar é um ato limpeza emocional
libertação stress
então a nossa sociedade é uma farsa
limpinho chorar sou fraco
precisamos larsson audições vez que a
gente tomar a frente dos outros
até o momento a lidar com o dia da raiva
[Música]
primeiro eu deixei de vir a instalar-se
no encontro vai reunir o povo
os princípios estava satisfazer as suas
finais
então alguém em todas as funções
soluções meninas
a tcheca
basta a apresentação não tem que ser por
faltar à verdade é que a pergunta gostar
deixamos quando aceitaram os as coisas
acontecem
é verdade que já percebemos que o manual
de instruções das intenções da nossa
sociedade não serve o propósito
então minha pergunta é será que podemos
construir um manual de instruções de
isenções universal que todos possamos
utilizar para nos orientar a nossa vida
pessoal e profissional
a resposta é sim e não
sim porque por todos somos seres humanos
e temos determinados padrões de
comportamento
então se temos esses padrões de
existem determinadas formas que podem
funcionar por exemplo o psicólogo norte
americano paul ekman através de mais 40
anos da instituição descobriu que
existem 71 sonhos universais são os
preços que nós prestamos através das
mesmas pressões sociais exatamente da
mesma forma seja um visitante do japão
de portugal ou da guiné
então nós podemos aprender com esse
elemento universal como é que podemos
identificar emoções através das pressões
sociais
no entanto nunca vamos conseguir criar
um manual de instruções que seja
universal e igual para todos porque
porque apesar de sermos todos uns somos
também únicos e reagimos de forma
diferente
nós temos iguais temos internas e
externas
então por exemplo quando eu estou
ansioso sim normalmente um aperto no
país
mas vocês podem sentir outra sensação
cultural do tempo
a dor de cabeça pode ser dor de barriga
o formigueiro na barriga podem começar a
suar
temos reações diferentes e quando estou
chateado qual ganha eu gosto resolver de
imediato e falar de imediato e isso
funciona para mim mas para muitas
pessoas têm primeiro que reclamar
tem que estar nos seus passos e só
depois é que vão falar que todas as
abordagens são válidas
o importante é vermos o que funciona
para nós então não existem fórmulas
mágicas porque a energia está dentro do
nosso e dentro de cada um de nós
então qual é a função a solução é
desenvolvermos o nosso autoconhecimento
emocional é desenvolvemos as nossas
competências emocionais para
conseguirmos construir queda um de nós
o seu próprio manual de instruções das
soluções personalizadas aceitar e
compreender quando estava no técnico
se eu tivesse aceitado e compreende das
minhas intenções
eu tenho percebido que ela estava enviar
uma mensagem
eu tinha percebido que era normal sem
ter culpa porque eu estava a mentir às
pessoas que mais amo na vida eu tenho
percebido que culpa estava dizer que
estava a viver mas não estava a viver
conforme os meus princípios e valores
a culpa estava estava enviar uma
mensagem que o recusa a ouvir todas as
emoções
enviamos mensagens nós é que não fomos
educados em termos funcionais para
perceber a linguagem intenções
então se eu teria aceitado e compreender
as minhas emoções e tinha percebido que
era normal está ansioso porque não
queria diziam dele minha família eu
tinha percebido que é normal estar
triste porque estava a tentar fazer um
curso que não estava
eu tenho é possível que a decisão
emocionalmente mais inteligente era
contar a verdade para ser sincero era
assumir primeiro para os outros é
assumir para mim e para os outros que eu
não queria continuar no curso que eu
queria desistir mesmo sabendo que não
fazia o que queria fazer na vida
mesmo sabendo que estava perdido
nossa procura
às vezes um pouco obsessivo pela
selecionada
esquecemo-nos que todas as emoções são
necessárias para nos sentirmos coisas em
todo lado vemos males que nos dizem que
a felicidade está na hungria mas a
verdade é que a felicidade está na forma
como lidamos com todas as emoções ser
feliz é também sentir medo raiva ou
tristeza por todas as emissões são
positivas com o cantor roberto carlos se
chorei ou se sorri o importante é que
emoções eu vivi
[Aplausos]